at Porsche Nelson he was asked to write
the autobiography of their life in five
chapters she wrote one and I walk down
the street there's a deep hole in the
sidewalk I fall in I'm lost I'm helpless
it isn't my fault and it takes forever
to find a way out - - I walk down the
same street there's a deep hole in the
sidewalk I pretend I don't see it I fall
in again I can't believe I'm in the same
place it isn't my fault it still takes a
long time for me to get out three I walk
down the same street there's a deep hole
in the sidewalk I see it there I still
fall in it's a habit but my eyes are
open I know where I am and it is my own
fault and I get out immediately for I
walk down the same street there's a deep
hole in the sidewalk I walk around it
after five finally I walk down another
Street
some of us hear a different drummer and
we must march to the music that we hear
all of you have some music playing and
all of you have a heroic mission there's
no accidents in this universe we all
show up here with a purpose there's an
intelligence that is a part of
everything and everyone and all of us
are connected to it too many of us are
afraid to listen to that music and March
to it you out there I know you have a
book you wanted to ride I know there's a
composition you wanted to compose I know
there's a song you want to sing maybe
you want to raise horses out in Montana
maybe you just want to travel and see
the world maybe you want to go into a
relationship with someone but you've
been afraid to but your heart says it's
the right thing to do I've known what my
music is it's playing right now as I
stand here in front of you with and as I
sit down and write my books and tell the
world what I know are my truths I feel
always completely on purpose and
fulfilled and no time will I ever come
to the end of my life and say what if my
whole life has been wrong whoever you
are whatever that music is however
distant it may sound however strange
however weird others may interpret it to
be don't get to the end of your life and
know that you're going to leave and not
have it played yet don't die with your
music still in you you just watch -
amazing clips from Wayne Dyer take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can
to your business and your life belief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]